[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 63rd episode of dirty chess tricks
in this episode i am going to show you
one of the very aggressive line
and in fact a high profile trick against
berlin defense from the white
perspective
the opening arises after the following
model
e4 e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 bishop to b5
and now the trademark berlin move knight
to f6
okay the main line continues with castle
on the king side
now black destroyed the white center
with knight captures e4
and accordingly white happily put the
rook on the e
file there is a double attack
black plays the move knight to d6
counter attacking the white bishop
and here white plays knight captures e5
setting up a small trap that if
black foolishly take this bishop then
after knight capture c6
just at the seventh move of the game
white obtained the black queen
so that's the reason why here black
generally continue with
bishop to e7 renewing the threat of
capturing the bishop
and accordingly the best place for this
bishop is
bishop to f1 okay
knight captures e5 rook captures e5
castle on the king's side unpinning the
black bishop
and after a white claim in the center
with d4
the most natural response in the world
bishop to f6
attacking the white rook
so you can see this line is pretty much
forced and if you are facing a berlin
defense player
it is almost a guarantee that you are
going to reach this position
in 99 of your game
well we reach to one of the most
critical position
and if you check this position in any
database
you will find out that white has played
universally
rook to even where a solid middle game
can continue from both the side
however at this point i am going to
recommend
a very nasty and high profile tricky
move
bishop to d3 sacrificing your exchange
just at 10th move of the game
wow so there should be something special
about this movar
well the first thing first wesley topolo
ex-world champion has fallen for the
streak
and his opponent sergey karyakin
crushed him just within 19 moves
which we are going to see in this video
and the second most important thing i
like to highlight here that
if you check this position in online
database
you can see that bishop to d3 has been
played
only in seven games
so imagine the surprise value you can
throw on the board
where your opponent literally has no
idea
how to handle this position
any black player will not resist to
capture this exchange
as it give him the clear edge in the
opening
however a small point if your opponent
doesn't capture this piece
and play any other moves let's say
knight to e8
then anytime we can drop back to even
and we can argue that black position has
been slightly compromised
however as happened in almost all the
games
black took this exchange thinking that
what can be possibly go wrong after d
captures e5
as my only knight has been attacked and
yes indeed this knight cannot go
anywhere
except e8 square but after that
it doesn't look like white has any
thread on the table
well that's the beauty about this
position
number one we have obtained the center
number two our two raking bishops
are looking at this castle king
and the third most important point is
our queen can
leap in on the king side very quickly
where black will find him defenseless
in most of the position
let's see how the game continues as
karjakin show his home preparation
with knight to c3
now just for a second i am flipping the
ball
so let's say you are black in this
position
how you going to feel well that e pawn
is a real nuisance which stopping your
peace development
so naturally any black player
will continue with f6 or the moon d6
and that's where the real fun begins
would you believe if your opponent
continue here
with the move f6 then as per the engine
it gives plus 2 advantage
yuck you heard it right plus 2
which is of course close to winning
at that level now before i show you the
variation
i want you to pause the video and find
out the sequence
where by force white get the upper hand
are you ready let's start the first move
is very obvious
queen to h5
well all the time in this variation if
your opponent continue with
moves such as h6 then we don't need
second invitation
we are going to sacrifice this bishop
and
black can't take it as generally all the
variation
leads to the mating attack so that's why
the correct response here is g6
but after that yup
no surprise bishop captures g6 pawn
captures g6
queen captures g6 well it doesn't matter
whether black continue with king 2h8 or
knight to g7
they will transpose to each other
knight to g7 bishop to f6
black can't play queen to e7 due to
knight to d5
and then check is coming up from the f6
square
so accordingly the best response here is
rook to f7 defending the mate
and after that white can deliver this
accurate response knight to e4
once again the threat is very obvious
knight to f6 track
so black has to play f captures e5
but now you see the point behind the
move knight to e4
we can deliver this nice move knight to
g5
and after that however black wriggles
his position is completely lost
one of the game from the database
continue with
queen to f6 attacking on f2 and if
possible
create a checkmate thread so white has
to deliver good in a precise manner
and in fact he did with queen check
king to f8 and now very nice move
knight to e4 counter-attacking the black
queen
the game finished very quickly queen to
f5
queen to a cheat shack king to e7
and now the star move bishop to g5
forcing king to go to the only e6 square
and after that quinto at 6
and black simply resign the game
the reason is very obvious if king to d5
then after rook to d1 check apparently
there is a mate in 10 so you can find it
by yourself
and the other option rook to f6
doesn't work here because we don't need
to take this rook
we can take first of all this knight and
now
the open king the trapped rook
an extra pawn gives white a picturesque
attacking position
so that would happen if your opponent
continue with
blundermoon ap6
well naturally enough topolo here
continue with
d6 not only attacking the pawn
but liberating his light squad bishop
but even this is not enough as white
continue
with his energetic style queen to h5
remember a fat six then bishop at six
and black can resign the game so the
obvious response is
g6 after that
karjakin continued with very sneaky move
queen to at 6.
now the threat is very obvious bishop to
g5
and we will see quickly why f6 is not
possible in these positions
so the natural response is d captures e5
which topalov played in the game and in
fact
many of your opponent will play it
thinking that now bishop g5 is not
possible
as i can play the move f6 and neutralize
all white attack but guess what
after bishop to g5 indeed
there is no f6
why what's the reason well the answer
is very obvious first
we have this lovely check
remember king cannot go to the etched
square because of
queen to f8 and we have a chat mate
so that is right out of the equation
the only defense exists here is rook to
f7
but after that white can deliver this
forcing sequence
bishop captures f7 king takes f7
now not immediately queen captures at
seven but
we have the in between moon rook to d1
attacking the queen and after queen to
e7
and the move queen captures at seven
again black king has to go to the e6
square
after that we can continue with
queen captures g6 and at the end of the
sequence
not only white has gained all of his
material
but he has a clear extra pawn and look
at this pathetic black king
which is hardly going to survive in the
upcoming
middle game
so obviously enough topolo doesn't fall
for it and he continued with
queen to d7 moving the queen out
but unfortunately it doesn't stop the
plan
which white was intending to do
yup knight to e4 and now
there are some huge problem on the black
king side
he tried to defend with f6 but
as we know in this line that f6 is
always
a terrible move and the straightforward
response is
yup bishop to c4
so that black has to block the check
with the only move
rook to f7
well the game lost it for only two moves
white delivered this deciding blow
knight captures f6 jack black has to
take it
and after bishop captures f6 we have a
picturesque attacking jester on the
board
where white is threatening queen to g7
checkmate
and unfortunately for black even though
he can see it
he cannot stop it
if the chess engine suggests that black
has to play queen to e6
give up the queen in order to save the
mate then
you can understand how pitiable
black position is in this variation
that's it guys i hope with this video i
have encourage you
to add this line in your rap router
starting with
bishop to d3 this wonderful exchange
sacrifice
and even though when black accept this
and then play the move knight to e8
with this two wrecking bishop and the
quick queen slider
gives white a hell lot of attack
which not many black players are ready
to face it
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care